the Berlin aka under-19 squad couldn't
have asked for a better start of the
season today they're looking to extend a
four-game winning run more than half of
the players have roots in Turkey as such
they're often referred to as the Turkish
club which angers some of the team the
only thing that distinguishes me from a
complete German with German roots is
that I also have Turkish roots and my
parents are Turkish but I think that
should not matter I was born here I'm as
much German as anyone in Turks are
Germans with a Turkish culture we live
in this culture and that's completely ok
Germany is generally a country with many
cultures a Bavarian also has a different
culture than someone from Hamburg this
bustling community club is proud of its
diversity the club are keen to point out
that the head of the youth department
Doreen and goalkeeping coach Anna are
Germans without migration backgrounds
they say their club lives and breathes
multiculturalism via fine we have 26
youth teams we're 20 to 30 different
nations play together integration has
never been an issue for us the boys play
football here no matter where you come
from Poland Croatia Nigeria wherever it
god will here but it's not all kicking a
ball in the room next door youngsters
who can sometimes train four or five
times a week are sitting through a
lesson provided by the club it's a firm
believer that the kids also needs good
school grades to get on in society but
it's there a diversity that brings
adversity club president mehmet ali han
says racist hate messages and
threatening phone calls are on the rise
for his club it's increasingly difficult
to play clubs from the former east
he was particularly afraid of the game
in Chemnitz after recent far-right
demonstrations there they say they're
fans of Adolf Hitler everyone knows what
and of Hitler did I don't even want to
think about it anymore
barbecue night with one of the players
families an opportunity to play football
and share frustrations about what they
see a society turning a blind eye to the
attacks it's over couscous and sausages
that this club forges its reputation as
a success story for social cohesion